All right.
So let us revisit the
example from last lecture.
So we have a Markov chain
with two states, one and two,
and this Markov chain has
a single recurrent class.
All right.
And then also it's
not periodic right,
because we have self
transition of this type.
So as a result, this is well
defined and these steady state
probabilities from 1 to m, in
that case for us, m = 2, right?
So let us write the
system and solve
the system of linear equation
for this example here.
So what we have is pi
1 equals pi 1 times 0.5
plus pi 2 times 0.2.
So that's the first equation
that corresponds to j equals 1.
Now, for j equals 2, pi
2 equals pi 1 times 0.5
plus pi 2 times 0.8.
So we have a system
of two equations
with two unknowns,
pi 1 and pi 2.
Let us rewrite them, I
pass this one on this side
and this one on this side.
So we get pi 1 times
1 minus 0.5 minus 0.5
equals pi 2 times 0.2.
And this one pi 2 times
1 minus 0.8 is 0.2
equals pi 1 times 0.5.
We realize that these two
happen to be the same,
so they are not enough to
define a unique solution,
so we have to add
another equation,
and we know that these
are probabilities.
So pi 1 plus pi 2 has to
be one, and so now we're
going to keep one of these
two, let's say this one,
I'm going to write it here.
And we can rewrite it by
saying that pi 1 times 1/2
equals pi 2 times 1/5.
So now, we're going
to take that, replace
pi 1 equals 2/5 of pi 2
is the result of that.
And we're going to use that
pi 1 and replace it here.
So we end it by 2 times
2/5 plus 1 equals 1,
which means that from here, we
get that pi 2 equals 5 plus 2/7
so 5/7, and then we use
that and place it here
and we end up having pi 1
equals 2/5 times 5/7 equals 2/7,
and we check 5
plus 2 equals 7, so
these are real probabilities.
So the probabilitiy
that you find yourself
at state one at time 1 trillion
would be approximately 2/7.
The probability that
you find yourself
at state one at time 2 trillions
is again approximately 2/7.
So essentially what we have
here is the probability
of being in that state one
settles in a steady value.
That's what the steady
state convergence means.
It's convergence of
probabilities, not convergence
of the process itself.
Again, the process will
keep jumping back and forth,
but the steady state probability
will settle for a given value
here in one, that will be
2/7, and the steady state
probability in being in
two will settle to 5/7.
And finally in this
example, and more
generally when we have a single
class and no periodicity,
the initial state
does not matter.